go all right greetings and salutations
welcome back the gamespot cross kind of
funny my name is Colin Moriarty our
resident hockey nerd of course i'm here
with rammer from EA sports thank you as
always for joining us we appreciate you
being here having us glamour and you
were going to make a grand introduction
here Wow titles for me to be up here
alone I'm up Ben Ross yeah game playing
presentation producer also overseeing
some of the a sports hockey league stuff
which I'm sure we're gonna get into
awesome absolutely also working really
really close with our fans so if ever
get him up here a little top the people
awesome well thank you for joining us as
well I really have it to be here we'll
do our normal tradition of talking about
the island for 10-15 minutes and then
we'll get into the actual game you guys
are ready i'm liking NHL 16 other is
saying it's unbelievable you know I I
started playing the game and it won't
NHL 93 NHLPA 93 thing it was on Genesis
we're getting old and now here we are on
NHL 16 we r gettin old yeah well you've
been working on the series for for a
very long time Eoin I'm is my first one
so yeah count back from them is Louise
how is it shaping up up there in the EA
Canada fantastic yeah yeah we got some
really good moments and we got the
entire game open on the floor today for
everyone to place all over online modes
all of our game modes are there on the
gameplay new gameplay and presentation
the entire thing is all this the first
time for us we come to e3 with the
entire game open so not to use really
proud of where we are right now we took
a little bit to go but excited for the
launch of 16 awesome now I have to ask
the question and it's a hard question
but NHL 15 was not well received on ps4
and xbox one the game was fine it played
I thought I played great yeah but it was
missing mode which was very stripped
down how did you guys deal with that
feedback did you expect that kind of
feedback when you got it from the
players yeah well we push I know we
pushed really hard all the way through
to the end and then at the end we
couldn't get we knew when we understood
what what else we couldn't get in the
game with the eSports logically
specifically we knew our fans were to be
upset about that and that's why you know
once 15 launch we weren't started
working very very close with our fans we
instituted a game changer program we've
got 12 people representing the community
and their views we have analyzed skype
chat going there probably buzz in my
pocket right now that we bounce ideas
off up so they we went full disclosure
early on we said we understand we're
coming from with the depth of breath you
know game playing presentation first of
all gameplay present taste you don't
have great gameplay presentation doesn't
matter
what else you do so it's important we
nailed that right off the bat for a
shell 15 and then with the depth of
breast of the game modes that we're
missing we worked with our fans and the
game changers to really prioritize that
featureless what to bring back what to
bring i went to bring it back what the
most important elements of those are
which ones need changing and we went
something we went something we did
something never done before we expose
our entire feature set what we were
thinking early on to these guys who we
didn't you know we don't have a great
relationship with it was something we
were starting off and we give the entire
thing we said you know on Monday when
you guys go home the entire features
that might be on the internet so yeah
we're trusting you guys to build this
relationship with it's something we want
to build long-term for the future so
that we can bounce ideas off you as our
feature sets come together this year in
features come together Ben will hop on
there and asking about Poe checking and
different thoughts or different theories
around how we want Pope checking to work
and we get Felix feedback in real time
and leverage that feedback to make
changes so it's been a really really
great experience yet leveraging our fans
lifting the game changers to build any
shell 16 what are you know every year we
talk about the game and you guys always
identify two three four features in
terms of gameplay whether it's Pope
checking or something like that or it's
when helmets are flying off going until
it's flying off whatever it is that's
kind of popping off in a more realistic
way whatever it might be what is
identified this year for NHL 16 that you
guys went into an addition of course to
the the modes that we'll get into later
but what what were some of the key core
hockey things that you guys kind of
added into the game yeah so the real
thing there was to not do those surface
level things we knew they were bringing
back EA sports hockey league so trying
to get into great multiplayer gameplay
for us back of the studio we said
gameplay balance is king and it's always
important in any sports game but this
year it was going to be prime there's
going to be the most important thing for
us and say how can we make the game fun
to play from every single position on
the ice so we looked at features that
were going to complement that as much as
possible we didn't want to say oh we're
going to bring back glass breaking and
try to make the nets come off the
moorings better and stuff like that it
was going to have to be about how are we
going to make it fun to play with the
puck how's it going to be fun to defend
the puck what are you doing to get open
as an offensive player away from the
pocket what are going to do even if
you're the weak side defender how can be
fun to play that position so that really
led to the feature set which was around
pickups around skating and then really
going back to all our core mechanics as
well to look at passing shooting the
physics again looking at hitting we
added back stumbles and
sure that that had a really nice
progression all the way through so that
a big power forward can actually shrug
off checks where is it may be a small
sniper that if he's not dangling well
and you're going to lay them out into
the board so that was what's going to be
really important when we get into
eSports Hockey League game play and that
really helps us across the whole game
because our play now experience with NHL
stars where that balance is generated
from what we see from the real world of
hockey that plays that much better as
well I've always wondered as someone who
played hockey you know a great deal when
I was a kid all year round and then kind
of also played the video games and
always felt that they were you know very
different experiences you know being on
the actually on the ice isn't playing
the game and you can only capture so
much of the essence of it how do you
keep the game fun while you still keep
the game realistic in other words you're
playing the new jersey devils in the
early be late nineteen thousand so you
know they're going to play the trap and
that's gonna be awful and boring hockey
you don't wanna watch it you wanna play
it how do you kind of find you know
identify like you want these crisp these
crisp passes these sharp turns these
great shots in the slot great blocking
all this kind of stuff you know fluid
goaltending well the same time keeping
it fun so that it's not the more dead
punk era hockey that we kind of existing
today which I like but a lot of people
don't know yeah how do you kind of deal
how do you kind of like defensive and
goal-setting you know defensive hockey
and goaltending but a lot of people
don't like the one nothing of the 21
games they want the barn burners so how
do you balance the realism with this
still kind of Arkady nature of NHL yeah
yeah so that's that's the discussion we
have every single day we always talk
about the different type of players that
play our game the ones that want to
really like sweat it out and it's like a
hardcore simulation they want to see
when the sticks go through like even if
they're going through legs that they're
losing losing the puck off of those
little interactions so if you go to get
a puck in the corner it might stay in
the corner and it's bouncing around and
it's scrambly so when we look at our
default gameplay that's not necessarily
a prime focus there it's about having
control of the puck setting up the one
timers laying the big hits but when it
gets the online competitive play es
we're talking the gameplay we look at
all that stuff when we make sure that it
is a little bit more about sweating it
out and that's when those guys are
having fun playing and that's where
we're getting a lot of feedback in the
way that they want to play that style of
game but at the same time we need to
look back at the roots and why why the
game has been fun wise wise hockey
translate so well to a video game it's
because the sport itself is high-flying
there are big hits there's fights
there's there is high scoring games and
stuff like that so we want to make sure
that we do represent that
and you are playing with these players
it's what does it like to play with an
NHL player the twitch part of the game
shouldn't be the divide its we want to
make sure you feel like a vet chicken so
if you're opening the slot it isn't
about whether you can do something with
your thumb in the controller if you do
at the right time you're going to lay
into a one time or it's going to be bar
down and back the other guys net you're
going to be able to celebrate in the
glory and go horn going off and all that
stuff so definitely a balance there and
I think that comes through shorter than
the ratings of the players and making
sure that you feel like a veg content on
the ice because I wouldn't be able to
compete at that level when we talk to
when we talk to fans of other anyone who
picks up a game they expect it to play
like hockey but you asked him what
hockey is and what their what their what
they think authentic locky actually is
it different so many people and that's
what we have the different game sells
our default experience is much a little
more arcadey a little more loose people
say all hockey to me is fast fast paced
lots of hits get him he'll fight and
score lots of goals and that's more of
our default experience and then you get
the more authentic lucky guy he wants to
sit back and play the trap and blog at
the neutral zone so it's really trying
to nail both those experiences I need to
go more do I'm like like Ben was saying
it's trying to get more towards the
authenticity I'm curious about you know
the modes now that we know we can kind
of get into this obviously bring becky
ashl and all these kinds of things that
you guys you know weren't able to get
into the current-gen versions of the
game but obviously the last gen version
to the game kind of remain the same what
is the full modes that kind of look like
to you guys you feel like it's like
robust enough to kind of game back you
know the trust you guys are talking
about with some of the most hardcore
players do you feel like when you put
this game out this is going to be kind
of the robust modes and kind of the
number of modes that I could keep people
engaged and excited about the game this
year yeah I think again we start time up
work with our fans early on we did more
research this year to understand what
our fans want every game understandings
like needs and motivations of our fans
as well if they're a single player guy
one of the things that they want to see
in our game if they're a couch co-op
type of player or a team play type of
guy what are the things they want to see
help prioritize that list so this year
working with our fans able to bring back
the depth and breadth of our molds are
be a pearl starting the CHL working your
way through Simpson next ship some of
the basics that were there before but
not only stop and they're adding new
experiences as well so when you're
planning to be a pearl this year how you
play on the ice with our new progression
system is going to shape your character
if your guy likes to go out there and
score lots of goals gets lots of cysts
because you set your teammates up you're
going to go in your offensive categories
if you like to muck it up get lots of
light sold off two hits your
physical traits are going to grow so
it's not only just bringing back the
depth and breadth of those modes but
also added the new experiences as well
so we continue to take each one of those
modes to a new level because some guys
by our game and they just play be a pro
nothing but V approach that we neglect
be a pro there's nothing our game for
those guys so we got to make sure that
we understand that different modes of
people are playing and what they want to
see in our game so that's why it's so
important we're talking to fans every
single day getting their feedback and
we're filling it with them but how I'm
curious about the analytics you guys see
the beauty of these consoles and
obviously last gen consoles do is you
could really see how people are playing
your game on a moment-by-moment basis
are there any thoughts to cut certain
modes that people might not be like you
guys pay attention say use ten percent
your resources whatever it is to click
on a dumping of this thing and you're
seeing a five percent return in terms of
gameplay back are there anything you're
identifying that people aren't messing
around so much with that you could say
like let's get rid of that and make room
for something new well I think it's a
conversation we have every single day
whether it's whether it's molds whether
it's features where features blimp
features because we have a fun in on
time we know every single year their
game is going to come out on September
and so every day we're not working on
the game is a day wasted essentially so
if we're not spending our time of the
most important things the most efficient
thinks the return on that time it's not
the greatest so that's why again it's so
important worth of fans so we can dial
in figure out where we're spending your
time to when you spend time on Pope
checking or non hitting on the goalies
because we're not efficient with our
time at the end that fan is the one who
suffers shop and I'm sorry I agree so
like having having the guys coming to
our studio and like grammar is saying
being on the skype chat all the time
being able to throw them ideas that just
allows us to take what is already a top
10 list we know what people want the
very vocal and passionate about what
they want so we've got those lists but a
matter of something moving from nine to
eight moving its way up to it gets the
one as we cross items off that list
making sure that we're always working on
the most important thing really need
analytics to is now we can track players
and when they play our molds and be a
pro and if we see that most of people
are getting to halfway through the
season and fallen off we need to sit
back and look at that day to understand
what's that what's that trying to tell
us what's happening halfway through the
season we're starting to lose people
right so really leveraging again the
analytics to just build better
experiences throughout the board what
about the level of granularity in the
modes that already exists one of my
favorite things to do I don't often play
and I play NHL every year but I don't
play it online yeah I probably I'm not
good enough I like to play season mode I
like to kind of be at GM I kind of like
to manage my team yeah there comes a
point where all you know be garth snow
and kind of just go which is you know
good or bad depending on your
perspective good now probably bad four
or five years ago and kind of just
manage my team simulate the games how
deep and granular do you want those
modes to go because I already feel like
they become very deep I remember I used
to in NHL 94 I used to keep the stats by
hand on a piece of paper and a binder
for everyone and use out of town scores
to fill in the standings and be real
nerd eval you guys introduce obviously
in the mid-90s your season mode and all
these kinds of things creating a player
it we've come so far that things are so
granular do you think they can go deeper
and you want to make them deeper so you
really get that GM feel or you really
get just that managerial for your
addition to being able to play the
actual game absolutely when it goes deep
as our fans want us to go but same thing
I've been talking about before is that
balance between authenticity and how you
know how far they want to go if it's two
details and we lose some that authentic
see lous some of the fun factor
associated with their right so I was
just getting that balance right and tell
me a little bit about the announcing
because doc is amazing right absolutely
amazing I don't know where Craig bounced
around here somewhere but Greg's out of
hockey fan i watch hockey constantly and
he loves he loved just listening a doc
and how he ramps up he gets excited how
was it working with with with Dakin and
old trick to kind of got to get their
feel for hockey which is so very unique
I think compared to a lot of other
announcing duos what was that experience
kind of like a metal bezel on the studio
with them every single day so yeah so
it's amazing exactly as you said so the
best part of the day is actually when we
get into the studio in the morning
before the mics are on you got doc
walking through the door telling us the
story that's just something you'll never
forget he's always got a new one I think
we could sit down with them every day
and we're always telling I'm like you've
got to write a book because more people
need to hear these stories is just
amazing and then just his character so
we heard from fans playing the game
after the after you put out the first
time we're really happy with the first
year of it but capturing that emotion
they're saying aww you really gotta nail
that goal call and so we worked on that
a lot this year we also worked on
ramping up that emotion during play so
we're recognized now whether
you're pinning a team in you have that
energy that he gets that much more
excited so I think that's that's just
our job to keep trying and trying and
trying to capture that energy because he
is very unique and that's why he's
amazing at what he does and that's why
people love to listen to him broadcast
games and Eddie complements them so well
I think he's been a student being
underneath doc listen to what it's like
to be a broadcaster and obviously brings
a lot of his hockey expertise and that's
why he's in the role that he's in and
then it's the same thing for us working
with Ray it's great to have somebody so
close to us in the studio and when he
comes in he gives his perspective and we
try to do that too it's the authenticity
side of asking ray well ok you're you're
commentating on this play for mice level
and we get more sort of the the analysis
side from Eddie and breaking down a play
and just getting their hockey expertise
the things that they've seen stuff that
other people never see in terms of the
experience what it's like to be a player
and you work your way through a be a pro
season you're going to hear from Eddie
and some of the sort of the anecdotes of
what was like to play in that first game
and stuff like that so I think even some
of that commentary is really great for
somebody who might not ever get an
experience to step on and do some of
these arenas at a professional level was
there a list of vocabulary words that he
had to use [ __ ] in the puck into the
corner of fluttering the pocket of the
slot waffle boards or yeah yeah well
yeah what soft with the old waffle board
I love I missed the waffle board blocker
I gotta be I gotta be honest it's a
classy look speaking of speaking of
getting old yeah yeah exactly i mean I i
played goal when i was a kid and I
almost I was just at the tail end up
getting the ball the black vaughn walker
and all this get the wave and all that
kind of stuff and i would look back and
I'm like there's something classy and
about the Billy Smith kind of style of
gold honey but I digress the other thing
I'm kind of curious about with him in
particular is a lot of his excitement
seems to be from his own authentic
surprised about what's happening in the
game at the time and that's what his
ramp up circo or ramp up so exciting do
you have to fish that out of him or is
he good enough where he can kind of fake
it because he's obviously not watching a
live game I've always been really
curious about how he comes off as so
authentic even though he's not
situationally watching a game yeah so
surprised is a little bit different
because obviously we know kind of what
we're going to tackle in today but we do
jump around a lot so we want to make
sure that any of that energy is there
and we want to make sure we capture it
so we also can't burn them out we can't
right there okay let's do gold call
for 700 players in the league and
capture that off into a three for three
days straight yeah so yeah so obviously
there's there is a balance there but we
don't script anything for him we sort of
we give them a context and that's we're
sort of in the moment we can say all the
puck just the puck just bounce off the
boards and a player came through to chop
it and missed go so he does sort of get
kind of an element of surprise to sort
of jump in and try to think of things on
the spot but at the same time you can't
quite get what it is in the real world
and that's why we just have to keep
trying right and we've tried different
things like putting real world footage
in front of them last year Eddie was
commentating on on replays and we're
actually putting the replays in front of
them because when it's more of a an
analysis it is sort of one to one it's
exactly the same as they are watching a
replay on their telestrator in the real
world so for us to put a youtube clip or
something like that from like a one time
or something like that then that kind of
does match one to one so I don't think
that in that case it's much different
but there's obviously some technical
challenges for us to for their
mentioning names and of teams and
players and stuff all over the place for
though for our audio artisan software
engineers to put that stuff together and
stitch it together there's a some big
technical challenges there too and
absolutely they've been really excited
to work with us because we're amazing
what they can do the same is what you're
saying coming in and say like wow what
an amazing commentary team and then doc
worked on some video games in the past
and you when we started working with him
day one he was just like wow it's
incredible what you guys can do now so
it's been a really fun relationship for
them to realize what we can do
technically and trying to continue to
push that bar and have them that
invested doc will sometimes come to it a
new day and say I was just writing up
some stuff last night we're like well
you didn't have to do that and you kind
of put it in front of us so it's been
really exciting awesome uh I have a
question that I'm actually really
interested in your answer to this
because typically teams will play in the
same barn for 10 15 20 30 40 50 60 years
my islanders are moving to Barclays now
what is the situation for your team to
have to now recreate that that new
building that you haven't had a bother
with for a long time and discard Nassau
Coliseum um do you send people to the
building to kind of take pictures and
figure it out are you just looking at at
video of pregame you know
what is that situation like the kind of
render of a new building like that and
render new barn and make it authentic
it's a little it's a little different
per building we've had people get in
there and send send drones around and
take pictures from all over their arenas
in some of the places sometimes you're
getting a lot of shots off of like getty
images and things like that for some of
the nooks and crannies of the arena
because i just go too crazy detail
you're sort of see in the nuts and bolts
of like down the tunnels and stuff
depending on some of the shots you get
we're flying around with some people
like with the game open on the floor
they're amazed at the level of detail
just in the ice and sort of it around
the scratches on the boards and things
like that so we definitely want to get
to that and capture that because that's
what fans are after they want to know
hey there's a section that I sit in or
these are my season ticket seats and
there's this sign and then they go there
and they're like you guys have that in
there so we definitely want to keep
surprising people with a level of
authenticity that we get to I think that
when we get a new arena or the art team
kind of goes like ah we just we just
finished building this one and now
they've moved to another one but I think
that it's also exciting for us go that's
something new that we can put into the
game so when the real world changes for
us unlike a game where you're sort of
writing the script from scratch your
sort of waiting for those things that
happen to be able to release a new level
like like so to speak so it's kind of
neat when they do something like that
and barclays is such a unique venue that
yeah that's what we're asking us like is
this exactly where the jumbotron is and
this is this exactly where the seats are
and we've had to do some unique things
on our side in the rendering side
because of the way that our gameplay
cameras work before and just where some
of their overhangs of some of the
balconies are they've created some like
technical challenges for us not just our
artists the challenges so you'll see
right not to come by when you play it
you look gonna bark lazy the scoreboard
is actually not over so late oh yeah
that's all Center it's uh it's
interesting I know she may find one of
the nets to nola but yeah so weird
there's some challenging seats in there
for sure maybe they should have planted
a little better but I'm glad they didn't
move the Kansas City so I'll take it um
all right I I'm curious about you know
and i know this is more of a business
question but i'm curious about your
thoughts it's the kind of creative guys
that are you know leading teams making
this game every year how do you feel
about NHL on the future a platform as
opposed to a game in other words what I
mean is well NHL EA sports NHL one day
turn into something that it's just
releasing them consistently updated as
one singular product supposed to kind of
a yearly sort of thing a lot of people
are asking you know why buy this game
every year when they can just they give
you ten dollars over the roster updates
or the roster updates are free although
you said to put him in manually which is
the nerdy ago through the release thing
in Newsday every day and she whose
release and change it around hope your
battery doesn't die to pretend o cart
you come up we've come a lot further
than that now but is there a future for
the annualized sports game going forward
you think or you think it's gonna become
something more unified where you pay
piecemeal for updates I think I think
all guys gonna get there I think that's
where the future is going to be I think
how fast we get there is still to be
determined but for us and we're taking
steps towards that right now really
start to translational more of a live
service with hockey ultimate team and
having promos running all the time you
contd coming out with our roster updates
Colin its Greg you got two minutes left
thank you Greg no problem love you a lot
buddy I ate some beans a second ago they
weren't terrible you're in for you're
dropping rammer here you try to tell me
about hey you didn't want to wear the
IFB though I'm sorry right we go yeah so
we're talking wish for taking steps to
worse that knowing that you know that's
probably the future we want to start you
know drive the NHL business like a live
service make it you're around and get
her keeper fans engaged keep the
conversation going year round as well
with our fans so we're taking steps on
the Dalton side so that when it when it
does come full bore that we're ready and
set for it and what what state are the
lash and versions of the game in so are
you guys going to be really see notes
for they come at least this year and
then the coming years are you going to
stop support of those so this year we
have any shell 16 legacy Edition
essential legacy Edition milla 16 on it
so limited feature set roster updates
kind of license are things like that man
we'll see we'll see what the future
holds after that awesome uh it's a
loaded question but on a scale of 10 to
10 how good is john tavares and the
answer is 10 of course but i'll let you
kind of its ban on that one in real life
or ya know in real life yet real life
entertainer paula nobody cares about
John Tavares excited is you one minute
left one minute remaining everybody is
ridiculous he's feature MEP yeah I
actually gonna be P and we were talking
about before the show but since you know
you guys are such big hockey fans like
me a the final you enjoyed the final
Blackhawks lightning you guys well the
entire flat last year so nice to have a
maid run on playoffs last year ought not
to have the first round this year the
playoff hockey has been unbelievable and
I watched many games already sent hockey
fan so it's great awesome awesome Greg
we're wrapping over early since you're
just gonna keep saying things in the
microphone know what this is just the
life you asked for it is the life I
asked for that should i love you
I love you too but these guys are really
good guests they were going comradery
with them oh well hockey fans they can
identify other hockey fans they call
Jersey sweaters too yeah I'm sure they
do the neck in 10 seconds nope that was
a new thing to Greg is that even know
Jersey for guys all right we're going
three Ramu been for me a sports NHL 16 x